Modern Life is deeply attracted to the
idea of progress in the 18th century as
European societies became ever richer
and more technological the conventional
view was that mankind was firmly set on
a positive trajectory from savagery and
ignorance towards prosperity and
civilization but there was at least one
18th century philosopher who violently
disagreed and who continues to have very
provocative things to say to our own era
jean-jacques Rousseau was born to an
educated watchmaker in Geneva in 1712
when he was 10 his father got into a
legal dispute and the family was forced
to flee Geneva from that point on
Russo's life was marked by deep
instability in isolation as a young man
Rousseau went to Paris and there was
exposed to the opulence and luxury that
was the order of the day in Austria
regime Paris it was a far cry from his
birthplace of Geneva a city that was
sober and deeply opposed to luxury goods
but then one day in 1749 he read a copy
of a newspaper the method of course that
contained an advert for an essay on
subject of weather recent advances in
arts and sciences had contributed to
what was called the purification of
morals in other words was the world
getting better Rousseau experienced
something of an epiphany it struck him
that civilization and progress had not
in fact improved people instead they had
eggs acted a terrible destructive
influence on the morality of human
beings who had once been good Russa took
this insight and turned it into the
central thesis of what became his
celebrated discourse on the Arts and
Sciences his argument was simple
individuals had once been good and happy
but as people had emerged from their pre
social state and joined society they had
become plagued by vice and sin in this
work and in its twin the discourse on
the origins and foundations of
inequality Rousseau went on to sketch
what it would have been like at the
beginning of history Anna Dilek period
that he called the state of nature a
long time ago when men and women lived
in forests and had never entered a shop
read a newspaper the philosopher
pictured people more easily
understanding their own minds and so
being drawn towards essential features
of a satisfied life a love a family
respect for nature and or the beauty of
the universe a curiosity about others
and a taste for music and simple
entertainments the state of nature was
moral and guided by spontaneous pity
empathy for others and their suffering
so what was it about civilization that
Rousseau thought had corrupted people
and led to moral degeneracy Rousseau
claimed that the march toward
civilization had awakened in people an
unhealthy form of self-love a more pop
he called it something that was
artificial and centered around pride
jealousy and vanity Rousseau argued that
this destructive form of self-love had
emerged as people had moved into cities
and there had begun to compare
themselves to others and created their
identities solely by reference to their
neighbors civilized people had stopped
thinking about what they wanted and they
felt and merely imitated other people
entering into ruinous competitions for
status and money and losing sight of
their own sensations Rousseau is forever
associated with a term noble savage
because it was his work that described
the innocence and morality of our
ancestors and contrasted it with modern
decadence at the time Rousseau was
writing European society was fascinated
by the plight of the native North
American tribes reports of Indian
society drawn up in the sixteenth
century had once described the Indians
as materially simple but psychologically
very rich and interesting communities
was small close-knit egalitarian
religious playful and martial however
within a few decades of the arrival of
the Europeans the status system of
Indian society had been revolutionized
through contact with the technology and
luxury of European industry Indians now
longed for guns alcohol beads and
mirrors rates of suicide and alcoholism
had risen communities were fracturing
and factions were squabbling the modern
world had ruined the lives of people who
had once lived happily in the state of
nature
Rousseau's interest in natural goodness
made him very interested in the idea
though not quite the reality of
children in 1762 he wrote Emil or on
education perhaps the most successful
book ever written about how to raise
children Rousseau suggested that
children were born naturally good and
that the key to raising them was
therefore always to prevent their
corruption by society this idea was
widely influential parents who it before
this time seen their children as wicked
or at best as blank slates now viewed
them as found sub wisdom and tried to
give them a childhood full of play and
visits to forests and lakes Rousseau
became the inventor of child centered
education he was also a great proponent
of breastfeeding declaring let mothers
deign to nurse their children and morals
will reform themselves nature's
sentiments will be awakened in every
heart and the state will be re peopled
it was he knew a bit of a hyperbole but
it spurred a wave of breastfeeding even
among the wealthy who long disdained the
practice artists rushed of paint and
honor the new vogue for breastfeeding
because Rousseau so closely valid human
beings in their original state it
followed that in the novels he wrote
Rousseau also constantly celebrated
intense feelings rather than great deeds
or social events in his novel Julie
written in 1761 Rousseau depicted the
excitement and anguish of an upper-class
woman caught in a love triangle between
her sensitive tutor and her boring but
socially sanctioned aristocratic match
Rousseau's contemporaries might have
seen Julie as unwise and her feelings as
a passing fancy
but Rousseau painted her love in a
higher light he urged us to see its
grandeur depth and honor in his writings
about his own life Rousseau was
similarly romantic or what one might
unkindly call self-absorbed in his
famous confessions one of the first-ever
autobiographies Rousseau spent pages
exploring his inner life how frustrating
he found shopping the surprising feeling
of tenderness for his ex's new partner
or the joys of gardening to him
these weren't trivial or self-absorbed
topics they were part of an important
task to show what living is like on the
inside
I have conceived of a new jar of service
to render to man he boasted to offer
them the faithful image of one
amongst them in order for them to learn
to know themselves Rousseau died in 1778
aged 66
his reputation has continued to grow he
was from beyond the grave one of the
heroes of the French Revolution and he
became an icon to a great many artists
and writers of the 19th century Rousseau
can be considered as one of the founding
figures of what we now know as the
Romantic movement an ideology
responsible for valuing the primitive
over the civilized the child over the
adult the passionate lover over the
calmly loyal spouse the modern world
despite its addiction to status
machinery and capitalist values in many
ways continues to be profoundly romantic
in its heart it's astonishing that so
much of what we take to be common sense
or just natural can directly be traced
back to the work of one not always wise
but always highly intriguing and
provocative thinker
you